si ha sido una reunión de emergencia del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
a petición del reino unido- y apoyada
por otros países como francia y eeuu
para tratar las consecuencias del ataque
a la central nuclear
en ucrania quien ha participado también
en esta reunión el director general de
la agencia internacional de energía
atómica mariano gross y quien ha dicho
que afortunadamente ninguno de los seis
reactores que allí se encuentra ha sido
dañado porque el proyectil ha caído en
otro edificio donde no estaban estos
reactores y ha dicho que de momento no
ha habido ninguna fuga de material
radioactivo el mismo se ha ofrecido a
viajar a ucrania para inspeccionar las
nucleares y asegurarse de que no hay
peligro ha dicho que desde luego la
normalidad no va a volver hasta esa
teniendo en cuenta que esa central está
ahora mismo controlada por fuerzas
militares
occidente ha denunciado este ataque ha
dicho que es irresponsable e ilegal la
embajadora del reino unido ha ido más
allá ha recordado las palabras del
presidente vladimir putin de ayer
diciendo que todo estaba yendo según lo
ocurrido ella le dice usted sabe todos
los que estamos en esta mesa sabemos eso
no es así que ha subestimado al mundo
que ha subestimado la respuesta de
occidente la representante de eeuu ha
vuelto a pedir unanimidad para pedir a
rusia para exigir a rusia que frene
estos ataques que son tan peligrosos ha
dicho que el mundo entero ha contenido
la respiración mientras veíamos este
ataque a esa central nuclear en tiempo
real y esto no puede no puede volver a o
podía ocurrir de hecho le pedí a rusia
que se comprometiera en esa mesa de la
de la reunión del consejo de seguridad a
prometer que no iba a volver a ocurrir
rusia sigue negando que ellos han sido
los culpables dice que esto han sido
saboteadores ucranianos y que toda esta
situación no forma parte más que de una
campaña de desinformación en contra de
rusia el representante de ucrania le
dice que se deje de mentiras que él sabe
perfectamente lo que está pasando en su
país y que la pasada noche podría haber
sido la última noche de ucrania y del
resto de europa